alors qu'en est il de la situation dans
les écoles et dans les universités les
mesures sanitaires sont elles adaptées
sont elles bien d'appliquer on décrypte
la situation avec benjamin a marre
professeur d'histoire porte parole cgt
94 est avec rené chiche vice président
d'action et démocratie messieurs bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors jean michel blanquer a donc
fait le point sur la situation ce matin
on dénombre 81 établissements scolaires
et 2100 classes fermées contre 21 et 260
de la semaine précédente est ce que
cette évolution vous inquiète
benjamin a marre écoutez je vais vous
dire les choses très franchement c'est
pas la première fois qu ici je suis vous
m'entendez on vous entend continuer on a
juste là un problème d'âge les
continents l'occurrence c'est pas la
première fois que j'interviens ici sur
votre chaîne sur les questions de
rentrée scolaire
à chaque fois on alertant sur sur les
risques de cette rentrée et de fait
maintenant on est on est dans les dents
les choses concrètes là et donc moi j'ai
fait ma rentrée comme beaucoup
d'enseignants est en fait ces chiffres
ne veulent à peu près rien dire je vais
vous donner la réalité c'est qu'on va il
ya bien plus de d'établissement dans
lequel il y à des élèves qui sont
atteints par locaux vides donc des cas
de des cas positifs avérée des cas
contacts sauf qu'en réalité il ya une
totale opacité
deux de ces chiffres une téte à une
totale opacité dans ces éléments qui ne
remontent pas c'est à dire qu'il ya dans
les établissements le ont averti les
enseignants qui lie à 1/2 càc de decaux
vide mais on ne donne pas les classes
les noms et donc on se bat pas la
possibilité de circonscrire de savoir
qui a été en contact ou pas avec ses
élèves
la rs fait des investigations mais les
rapports les éléments sur lequel elle se
base pour pour fermer ou pas les
établissements ne sont pas transmis au
personnel ni aux familles
et moi j'ai des cas complet
- hallucinant j'ai le cas d'une collègue
l'a par exemple qui a fait le test est
positive
enfin l'on est là elle a fait part du
succès moi c'est plus compliqué a les
symptômes
elle a un certain nombre de symptômes et
donc elle a 2 elle a demandé à faire le
test sauf qu'en ce moment faire un test
ça à sa relève effectivement des travaux
d'hercule et donc elle se retrouve dans
une situation où elle n'a pas
d'interlocuteur on lui demande d'aller
essayer les laboratoires dans toute
l'île de france mais eux elle el dib
écoutez moi mon médecin refuse que je
reprenne sans avoir pu faire les tests
mais je ne sais pas si j'ai contaminés
ou pas et donc on a entre le problème
des tests le problème de l'absence de
transparence dans les éléments fournis
eh bien on peut vous dire une chose
les chiffres qui sont communiqués par le
ministre sont en réalité totalement
sous-évalué donc bien du mal ben jama
marla des dizaines de cas suspects dans
un certain nombre d'établissements qui
ne sont pas fermées mais qui devrait
l'être benjamin marc le temps de
réorienter peut-être votre caméra on va
entendre tout de suite
rené chis rené chiche pardon
vice-président action et démocratie
alors effectivement est-ce que vous
aussi vous vous constatez que finalement
il ya une certaine opacité sur la
question du nombre de contaminations
dans les écoles est ce qu'on dit ou
est-ce qu'on allait les réelles chiffre
est ce que finalement beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'on nous dit
aujourd'hui par les voies officielles
écoutez dans cette situation il ya
différents aspects et moi je voudrais
pas entretenir la psychose nous aller
dans le sens d'une critique permanente
de ce qui se fait même difficilement il
ya de quoi critiquer moi je voudrais
d'abord alerté sur la réalité c'est à
dire que le ministre tout dans une
rentrée normale
parti il n'est pas en situation
d'enseigner il n'est pas n'a pas reçu
comme tous les enseignants cet
accessoire que je tiens à vous montrer
parce que je ne voulais pas ressortie
depuis qu'elle a reçu
on voit très bien décrit vais peut-être
parce qu'on voit pas c'est pas très
clair à l'écran alors plastiques à
l'intérieur sur laquelle il n'a aucune
infection liée à l'intérieur duquel se
trouvent deux maladies sont supposés
être des moyens de se protéger
je compte est naturellement la vertu de
ces masques mais en revanche je constate
qu'elle empêche d'enseigner et là il
faudrait quand même le dire une seule
sous influence d'un protocole qui ne qui
est appliqué d'une façon aveugle et sans
tenir compte de la nature des choses
alors je vais bien que on agite quelques
cas positifs et quelques fermetures
d'écoles mais en réalité si on testait
tout le monde je dis bien si on testé
tout le monde on trouverait certainement
une centaine de cartes par établissement
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
tout faire mais ce n'est pas très
sérieux
la réalité c'est que d'autres
gouvernements ont fait d'autres choix
l'italie par exemple à ma connaissance
se vante d'avoir investi énormément pour
cette rentrée
cette rentrée d'ailleurs ils l'ont
préparé en quatre mois alors que notre
gouvernement et notre ministre de
l'éducation lui s'est concentrée sur des
vacances apprenantes et est arrivé au
dernier moment sans aucune aucun
préparatif sérieux parce que ce n'est
pas les deux masques que je voulais
montrer qu'ils constituent un préparatif
sérieux l'italie a considéré que ce qui
était important à l'école c'est
l'instruction c'est-à-dire que les
élèves et les professeurs puissent
travailler dans des conditions
convenables et ils se sont débrouillés
pour assurer la distanciation
nous on a supprimé la distanciation donc
tout le monde est réuni
et puis condamne à mort qui est non
seulement pas du tout une protection
mais qui en réalité un vecteur de
contamination puisque on n'arrête pas le
toucher les vols plupart des élèves ne
le portent pas correctement
et puis on est en train de créer à
l'intérieur d'une crise sanitaire ou
deviennent crise sanitaire spécifique
allait lui à l'éducation nationale car
je vous assure vous êtes présentateur
télé visuel vous bénéficiez d'une
dérogation
vous ne portez pas le masque sur le
plateau mais en sculptant seulement
seigner
avec wii vous êtes tous là même qui
regardent l'émission les invités sur le
plateau son maître en compte les uns des
autres et ne porte pas de match et il y
a dit avoir confirmation de cette
dérogation qui a été donné moi je vous
demande d'imaginer ce que c'est qu'un
chanteur d'opéra qui il demande de faire
son petit et son armée avec un masque
sur le visage ce départ fait sérieux
donc moi je suis professeur avant tout
je ne suis pas médecin je ne suis pas
dire blog je lève à me remonter sur des
chiffres en revanche j'ai en face de moi
des dérives qui souffrent et je croise
des professeurs qui souffrait du rebord
et quand même signaler que notre second
travailler dans la voix si on forme
dessus on va finir par créer des
pathologies nouvelles c'est à dire comme
jeudi les une pile sanitaires et syfy
qu'à l'intérieur d'une tricennale est et
je ne parle même pas de la crise morale
qui consiste à suivre les règles
rené chiche vous parliez des élèves qui
s'ouvre je vous propose alors pas
d'écouter des lycéens mais mais des
étudiants de suite quelques réactions
que nous avons recueillies et je vous
propose donc jamais à l'art ensuite de
réagir on les écoute
là c'est sûr que ça change des rentrées
habituel parce qu'il faut respecter le
port du masque un peu de distance
extra mais bon après on s'habitue quand
même assez vite et c'est lui assez
facilement en place dans l'établissement
et toulon le respecte donc ça va
s'habituer
c'est un peu particulier parce
qu'effectivement bon nous on pensait
être
en présentiel et on a des cours à moitié
en présentiel et en distance yale ce qui
fait qu'on voit pas toujours nos
professeurs à la fois derrière l'écran
et à la faculté donc c'est compliqué
mais mais espérons que voilà les choses
changent rapidement même si le
gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures donc on verra bien mais pour
l'instant oui on aimerait bien avoir
plus de présentiel à l'avenir ou qu'ils
aient une autre organisation
ça nous inquiète parce qu'effectivement
malgré la distance réglementaire et le
port du masque on sait pas si les choses
vont s'arranger ou pas et donc est donc
pour nous voilà on a on n'arrive pas à
dessiner l'avenir peu d'inquiétude c'est
vrai parce que beaucoup de deux
d'incertitude on ne sait pas trop
comment est-ce que ça va évoluer la
situation mais bon on espère que ça va
ça va aller en s'améliorant et que tous
les événements prévus par le master vont
pouvoir être maintenu après c'est pas du
tout donc on avance et on verra voilà on
entendait à l'instant benjamin marle et
les inquiétudes de ses étudiants vous en
tant que professeur qu'est ce qui vous
disent vos élèves ils sont contents
d'être là malgré tout c'est important
qu'ils soient présents dans les classes
malgré la situation et le manque de
moyens ce que vous nous dites
écoutez bien évidemment que pour les
élèves c'est difficile bien évidemment
que pour les collègues c'est difficile
je j'étais en heure d'information
syndicale avec mes collègues il y a
quelques jours et ils expliquaient leur
fatigue le ils dorment tout le week-end
il se couche très tôt ils sont épuisés
les élèves aussi bien sûr que c'est
pénible mais enfin même si le masque et
le test ne sont pas les seuls paramètres
de la lutte contre la pandémie emprunt
soyons sérieux c'est quand même deux
éléments qui sont cruciaux la
distanciation l'aménagement des horaires
tout ça ce sont des choses que nous
avons mis en avant oui l'italie était un
modèle d'ailleurs je le disais sur votre
antenne lorsque les italiens ne se sont
pas posé la question pendant des mois de
savoir s'il fallait effectivement
abandonnés une rentrée prématurée en mai
ou en juin
mais ils ont d'emblée proposé de rentrer
en septembre en prenant leur temps mais
pour autant le masque et le test sont
deux armes crucial et là dessus on va se
dire les choses
nous sommes à poil et la réalité c'est
qu'en ce que les chiffres présentés par
monsieur blanc caire sont largement
sous-évalué que dans les semaines qui
viennent les jours
qui viennent le nombre d'établissements
vont qui vont fermer vos pas être va
augmenter nettement que le nombre de
classes fermées va augmenter nettement
et que la finale ment la possibilité
d'une fermeture des écoles va se poser
clairement ce qui serait un désastre
donc on est dans une situation le
problème c'est que le premier le premier
problème si vous voulez c'est que
lorsqu'on est face à une crise il faut
déjà faire un diagnostic honnête et on
ne fait pas un diagnostic un diagnostic
honnête dans les rectorats dans le
ministère dans les établissements on est
en train de cacher la réalité aux
enseignants et aux familles religieuses
rené c'est très important à partir de ce
moment là comment est-ce que l'on peut
effectivement proposé un protocole
d'action adéquat si même le diagnostic
n'est pas honnête pour une et il est
temps de parole on va vous éviter
on va vous écouter rené chiche trente à
quarante enseignants d'un même lycée à
saint denis ont décidé d'exercer leur
droit de retrait pour dénoncer les
conditions sanitaires dangereuse
est ce que il y à des zones délaissées
par le gouvernement et est ce que
finalement on se dirige vers des
fermetures massives d'écoles dans les
jours dans les semaines qui viennent
bien d'abord moi je conseille à mes
collègues déjà de saisir la médecine de
prévention puisque ils vont constater à
l'occasion que l'éducation nationale n'a
pas suffisamment de médecins de
prévention et n'est pas capable de
répondre à des demandes des victimes et
a à ce moment là ils pourront au lieu
d'exercer un droit de retrait et qui à
mon avis est un peu discutable dans ces
conditions ils pourrons à ce moment là
qui a constaté réellement pas pris en
charge par l'instance qui devrait leur
proposer un aménagement de poste de
travail moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
pour qu'on ferme
évidemment les écoles je crois que nous
avons beaucoup souffert de cela déjà
précédemment pour la continuité de la
vie de la nation c'est essentiel
simplement les experts ne sont pas des
garderies et ce ne sont pas des endroits
où on met les gens ensemble et puis on
leur donne deux bouts de tissus et on
leur retour on les laisse se débrouiller
un moment donné faut être sérieux je
vénère - répondre à ce qu'a dit mon
collègue parce que ce qui est important
ce qui est important c'est de protéger
les personnes fragiles vulnérables
or les personnes vulnérables
précédemment bénéficié d'un certain
nombre de droits notamment une
autorisation spéciale d'absence qu'ils
auront été supprimés du jour au
lendemain c'est la raison pour laquelle
on se trouve dans les titres dans la
situation qui est décrite par mon
collègue et alliés qu'il ya
effectivement parmi nous des professeurs
fragiles ou qui risquent de faire des
formes compliquées de l'infection et ces
personnes là effectivement comme il l'a
dit seront envoyés au fond mais
attention ce n'est pas la totalité il
faut pas non plus généraliser nous avons
aussi besoin de retrouver un peu de bon
sens et moins que je réclame c'est que
on applique le protocole avec
discernement que le tronc tourne pas en
un ensemble de règles aveugle sur
lesquels nous s'arc boutent et qui finit
par aurait complètement marre le mot de
la charente quelques secondes à ce que
vous réclamez messi du bon sens comme
rené chiche lui mais le problème c'est
que ce que vient de dire monsieur chiche
quand les gens qui ne sont pas fragile
ils vont chez eux ils voient leurs
parents ils voient leurs grands parents
il voit l'art en cloud des gens qui sont
âgés autour de qu'est-ce qui se passe eh
bien le virus circule vers des personnes
très fragile et je rajouterais que mon
établissement aussi est en droit de
retrait et je vais vous dire le nombre
de cas concernés par des formes graves
de la maladie il y en a un paquet c'est
mon cas je vous rappelle que moi j'ai eu
la forme grave de la maladie que j'ai
passé quinze jours en hôpital et 12 en
réanimation
donc ça concerne beaucoup plus de monde
que cela et donc les comment dire ce que
je pointais eh bien je pense que ça une
gravité centrales est essentielle et que
c'est pas du tout périphérique
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation benjamin a marre je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire porte parole cgt 94
merci à vous également rené chiche
vice-président action et démocratie